this week twitter updated its micro
video sharing app vine with the ability
to take front facing video uh and in
addition to just like taking pictures
with the front facing camera you can
switch back and forth so you can take a
picture of yourself
and then switch it back and then take a
picture of your friends off in the
distance oh a bird yeah that's my
sister's parrot oh
exciting
so kobo has a brand new limited edition
premium e-reader it's called
the aura hd
now it's premium because it has a really
great screen this is the best screen on
the market let me check this out it's
pretty dope as the kids say the glow is
incredibly well managed the contrast is
great and you can adjust the font so you
can make them a little bit thicker you
can adjust the weight so if you're a
huge hardcore e-reader fan this is a
great e-reader when i first heard about
this i was really you know kind of mad
about it but this screen is really
probably the most fantastic e-reader
screen that i've i've seen now in
addition to redesigning the screen and
making it awesome they've also changed
the case now that might not be so
awesome they've they've added these sort
of little mountains
these little peaks on the back which is
nice if you're right-handed but if
you're left-handed and you have small
hands
it it might
you know be a little slippery because it
still has that slicker back are you
vining i'm biting you right now
it does have the problem of the amazon
ecosystem which is huge and of course
kobo doesn't work with that only the
kindle works with the amazon ecosystem
so if you're a hardcore reader and
you're part of kobo's ecosystem
awesome but if you're still part of
amazon you really love those kindle
singles and you're a prime user and you
like having those free
those free books to check out then it's
kind of a tough sell
you